hey guys welcome back to brain unity
Rebecca on 400 and today season 7 has
just come to a close about 10 to 20
minutes ago so we're gonna be going over
the rankings who won who lost and the
rewards which include an outline and
emblem and three ornaments as usual so
let's get started with today's video we
have real quick I just uploaded a video
this afternoon
it isn't a for honor video it's a little
bit different on a completely different
game but I did spend a lot of time on it
and it would greatly I'd be greatly
appreciated if you guys do check out
that video even if it's only for a bit
it's about a three minute long video so
hopefully you guys do have some time for
that we are getting into the actual
video today the standings were the
Vikings with three wins the Knights with
two in the samurai with zero but either
way guys talking about the rewards first
up as we have is the emblem and it's
going to be called serpent cycle and
this is only for the first and second
place winners in this case it is the
Knights and the Vikings those people for
that faction are going to be the only
people that are going to be able to
wield these is a circular emblem of two
serpent heads which I assume there are
serpent heads because of the name with a
little bit of fire in the middle of them
pretty cool but I'm probably gonna keep
my apology on one on my shoulder just me
personally next up is the outline and
this is very similar to the emblem but
remember it's a different colors
depending on your placement for the
season the Vikings won so they're going
to be eating this exact outlining gold
the Knights came in second so they're
gonna be getting this outline in silver
and the samurai in last so they're gonna
beginning this in bronze
sadly I'm a knight so I can't show you
what the gold version looks like but you
can kind of figure it out in your head
but I did get silver so definitely take
that and lastly are the ornaments and
the ornaments are only available to the
Vikings and since they won the faction
war and they can use it on every
character in the game it's called the
maleficient vengeance I believe think
I've said that wrong but it's faction
based meaning the Knights of Vikings and
samurai had different designs so we're
gonna go into that right now
she has a bokken on on reddit for this
image with the original link with all
three emblems together it'll be in that
link if you guys want to check that out
but for the Knights it is a medium sized
ornament with a blue gem in the middle
I assume that color will change
depending on the color of your armor but
I could be wrong and it has a small
serpent in the middle above the gym and
it also has a gold color scheme use but
with a few spikes on top and some
smaller intricate designs throughout the
whole ornament
Vikings are next with a very similar
blue gem with the serpent head on top of
it and some of these things protruding
out of the centerpiece of it and some
wavy designs within those protruding
things that coming out of it while not
as much as the Knights has it also has
some small designs as well lastly is the
samurai and the black flames you see I
believe are part of the ornament this
also has a black a gem that has stated
pretty like I said stated previously
will most likely change depending on the
color of the armored character also has
a serpent above that gem as well and
other than the flames it looks very
similar to the Viking ornament in terms
of the centerpiece so I'm not really
gonna go over that again and that guys
was the rewards in the end of the vase a
hope you guys did enjoy - really quick
questions before you leave though I like
you guys to answer in the comments down
below do you guys like these ornaments
and do you think season seven was worth
it or now that it's over or what do you
guys think of it personal thoughts I
think it's an OK season but I think it's
just another one in the book but let me
guys know if you think it was exciting
it was a shitty season or it's just
another thing so we can just get to
marching fire I'd love to know your
thoughts in the comments below yeah guys
like the view do enjoy subscribe if
you're new I covered the informational
side of foreign land that big balance
changes hero updates patch notes of
leaks all that good stuff with some
gladiator gameplay and some other stuff
coming in the future as well and that
guy's my two most recent videos will be
on screen if you guys do want to check
that out when that guys over esterday
thanks for watching the video and peace
out
[Music]